[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact rescuers are calling it a
Christmas miracle
a 26 year old man skiing in some remote
mountains in Austria was caught and
buried by an avalanche on December 25
when he failed to ski down the mountain
a friend called his mobile phone that
only heard a crackling noise he
contacted the authorities that quickly
mobilized a rescue team after several
hours searching they were able to locate
the skier because he was wearing an
avalanche transceiver a safety device
that emits a detection signal a rescue
team with the help of local police dogs
Doug the man out of the snow now the
average time a person usually survives
being buried by an avalanche is 18
minutes by the time they found and
extricated this man he had been buried
under the snow for five hours
incredibly other than surviving from
hyperthermia or experiencing some
hypothermia he was unharmed you know the
Bible says in the last days things are
gonna get very cold before they get very
hot and I'm not talking about climate
change
stay with us friends were gonna learn
more on this edition of bible answers
lie
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 or four
minutes we budget for each caller you
can also watch the program we're
streaming on Facebook at the Doug
Batchelor Facebook page or you can go to
the amazing facts it's simply amazing
facts facebook page and you'll see the
stream of the program coming from the
studio with that we're gonna have prayer
and get into tonight's program loving
Lord thank you for your blessings and
for watching over us for a year and Lord
we thank you for the power of your word
that goes forth and changes life I pray
right now that that word will come alive
again and touch hearts and just bless
Lord as people call them with your
questions that they get answers
discovering the truth that will set them
free we pray in Jesus name Amen well you
know I opened talking about this miracle
that just happened a few days ago this
man in Austria trapped in an avalanche
for five hours and got out alive other
than you know being a little bit cold
the rescuers say somehow he was able to
roll around where he had a small pocket
of air that he could breathe usually
you're kind of packed in concrete it
feels like when you're caught up in in
an avalanche
and then I said things are gonna get
very cold before they get very hot and
well we all know at the end there's the
lake of fire as a judgment for the lost
and even during the seven last plagues
one of those plagues says that men will
be scorched with great heat and I'm not
talking about global warming these are
the seven last plagues of the Great
Tribulation but jesus said even before
that you read this in Matthew 24 and
I'll start with verse 9 speaking of the
time of trouble they will deliver you up
to tribulation and kill you and you'll
be hated by all nations for my name's
sake and then many will be offended and
betray one another and heed one another
many false prophets will rise and
deceive many
and because lawlessness will abound the
love of many will grow cold Bible tells
us in the last days evil men and
seducers will wax worse and worse love
growing cold is one of the signs that
Jesus gives of the last days and the
lawlessness
I was just thumbing through some
statistics before we went on the air
regarding divorce you know divorce rates
have skyrocketed in in the last hundred
years I think it used to be maybe two or
three out of a hundred people that got
married would get divorced in you know
1865 right now about 42 percent of first
marriages end in divorce that's actually
believe it or not an improvement from
the 80s whereas up closer to 50% what
happened as a lot of people stopped
getting married they were living
together and so the statistics wouldn't
reflect a divorce because then they just
stopped living together interestingly
some people think well I didn't get it
right the first time second marriage
things will go better
60% of second marriages end in divorce
well maybe third marriage will be better
statistically 73% of third marriages end
in divorce and if you're curious the
average age for divorce is about 13 the
average length for those who experienced
a divorce is 7 years of marriage you've
heard of the 7-year itch well I guess
there may be some truth to that but
that's not God
plan the Bible says God said let not man
put asunder what God has joined together
but one of the signs is selfishness and
cold-heartedness and people's love
growing cold if you'd like to know more
about how you could have a successful
and a happy and a lasting marriage this
is for those who are married or you're
not married or you know someone married
anyone would be blessed by this lesson
it's called keys for a happy marriage
I'll send that to you for free if you
just call no strings attached
nobody's gonna show up your door and
harass you all you've got to do is call
808 three five six seven four seven now
that's the number for the free resource
one more time 808 three five six seven
four seven to call in with your
questions for your Bible questions 800
four six three seven two nine seven
that's 800 God says one more time for
six three seven 297 for your Bible
questions gonna go to the phones and
talk first with Chris calling from
Florida Chris you're on the air with
Bible answers live hello good evening
good evening thank you again for taking
my call and my question is really
quickly about 305 yes and I I refer to
revelation 22 verse soon okay go do you
want to read it are you gonna read it
sure you come in please in the middle of
the street on either side of the river
was the Tree of Life which bore twelve
fruits each tree yielding its fruit
every month and the leaves of the tree
were for the healing of the nation's
now just one thing I want to say in the
original you know it doesn't say each
tree it says in the middle of the street
on either side of the river was the tree
the tree is singular but anyway your
question about that my question is well
this refers to New Jerusalem right yes
New Jerusalem so why does how can we
understand how should we understand the
last part of it when it says that the
leaves of the tree will be a cure for
the nation's when everything will be all
right yeah everything in heaven is gonna
be perfect it doesn't mean there's no
more growth in heaven but let me give
you something to think about it does not
say here the leaves of the tree are for
the healing of sickness it says the
leaves of the tree are for the healing
of the nation's
now here in this world were divided by
nations the nations are divided by
patriotism politics culture race
language there's all kinds of divisions
in this world will we be divided in
heaven no and as the people right so
there will be no nation handed it so let
me the nations are healed well what that
means is when we gather in heaven under
the trees under the leaves of the tree
of life we are all going to be healed
from our divisions so I don't think it
keep in mind a lot of this is written in
sort of beautiful poetry I don't think
John is saying that sick people are
never gonna you're gonna come up and
they're gonna rub the leaves in their
wounds or something or be you know
choking down some tea from the leaves
it's simply saying that all of the
divisions of the nations are healed as
we gather together under this singular
tree of life and this is the same tree
that is in the Garden of Eden that you
read about in Genesis chapter 3 it never
calls it you know one of the trees alive
it says the V tree he is a definite
article it's so the one tree of life but
you know I've got a lesson we'll be
happy to share with you on that Chris
and it's it's her lesson talking about
God's free health plan because the tree
of life plays into one of the ultimate
health food in that those who eat from
the tree never die remember God chased
Adam and Eve out of the garden and God
said lest he eat of it and live forever
and so those who can continually eat
from the tree of life in heaven will
never die and he promises us eternal
life okay thank you so much for your
call Chris and I hope that you'll take
advantage of that study guide on God's
free health plan call 800
eight three five six seven four seven
we'll send it to you you can download it
for free if you go to the amazing facts
website amazing facts dot o-r-g talking
next to gk y am I saying that right
cheek eight question you're saying it
correctly I I had a question about
discernment so I know that you know
Solomon was praying for this sermon I've
been praying for determine because you
know you want to know what things are
coming from God in terms being on your
decisions and things like that but the
past few weeks have been they've been
very hard for me because I've been
trying to discern things but I get
certain feelings and I don't know which
ones are coming from God as they're
coming from my own self or things like
that so how can you know and discern
what's going from God and become not God
yeah from how do we discern between the
two voices well first of all the voice
of God is never going to tell you to do
something contrary to the Word of God
jesus said the Holy Spirit will bring
pure membranous things that I have said
so that's one thing is it matching up
with the Word of God
secondarily the voice and impressions of
God are going to be leading you forward
in becoming more like Christ you know
I'm just thinking as I'm talking I've
got a book that's called how do you
determine the will of God and in that
book it's it's a free booklet I'll be
happy to send you it basically goes
through 12 points and I'm realizing I
don't have time to go through all 12
points 12 points of how do you know the
will of God a lot of the points are the
same ways you would know how do you
discern the voice of God because it's
the voice of God that's leading you you
know now first of all we always go by
the word but sometimes you'll hear an
inner voice Isaiah talks about you'll
hear a voice behind you saying this is
the way walk II in it Elijah heard a
still small voice so is it okay GK if I
send you that the book called
determining the will of God yeah all
right I'll send you free copy that if
all you've got to do is call this number
and tell them the book it's 800
eight three five six seven four seven
and it got all the Bible principles and
one of the ways also to know is get good
Christian counsel the Bible tells us in
the multitude of counselors there is
safety you know when you're feeling
impressions you might bounce it off
Christian friends that you trust and say
you think God's speaking to me or this
my own mind playing games or is it the
devil now that every time you think
something it's not always the devil and
always gone God did give you a free will
and sometimes our minds wander of our
own and even James says were tempted
when we're drawn away of our own last
sometimes we can't always blame the
devil all right
with that opens up another line if you
want to call in with a Bible question
800 for six three seven two nine seven
talking next to David calling from White
Plains New York David you're on the air
with the Bible answers live I had a
question about Exodus 20:5 five where it
mentions the word badger okay and I'm
just saying that if you read other parts
of the Bible but a person was not
supposed to touch the skin of a let's
say for a legged animal so what is the
animal well it could have been a badger
the because the Bible says that certain
animals were unclean for food it also
said Joran supposed to touch him but
that's usually speaking of in the
context of a dead carcass because John
the Baptist wore a garment of camel hair
and a lot of the Hebrew tents were made
of camel skin and they use skin of
animals that were even unclean animals
once they had been tanned and treated
they weren't now I don't know that they
ever used pig skin for anything but they
they could use these unclean animals of
course they rode donkeys donkeys are
unclean he got a touch of donkey to ride
it yeah so the prohibition against
touching unclean animals he's speaking
of a dead carcass meaning you know if
you get around the dead unclean animal
don't be tempted to even eat it even if
you're hungry because they're they're an
abomination God says you know person
might have a dog shepherds head
dogs back then and they pet their dog
yes so that's an unclean animal dogs in
the same family as a pig they say and
the cat yeah I I'd avoid touching cats I
don't trust them
anyway not kidding I've I've got kids I
hope that helps a little bit David okay
thanks thanks I know you know I did hear
that that word for badger that's been
debated if it was you know the kind of
badger that we have because that Badgers
Badgers in the desert they're of a Sinai
or the Arabian Peninsula could be a
different animal than like the American
badger anyway thank you very much and
we'll talk next to Calvin calling from
New Jersey Calvin you're on the air with
Bible answers live hi good evening
pastor evening thank you for taking my
call yes I'm gonna keep the theme going
about I'm on screen foods um I'm
wondering about duck is duck included
and uh unclean birds it appears so it
appears that I think the Swan is
mentioned now some of the Hebrew names
for these birds when they translated
them the English some of it's a little
difficult but if I think if you look in
the King James Version under the unclean
animals it mentions the Swan and you
know a goose a duck would all be in the
same category the only birds that were
clean it mentions a lot of unclean birds
the owl is unclean all the Raptors were
unclean the birds of carrion were
unclean seems the only birds that are
mentioned as clean Birds is what you
would call a foraging bird and these are
the birds that kind of walk around in
the woods and they pick through things
like a turkey dove chicken you know
they're picking up seeds and bugs and
those were typically the ones ducked me
they'd a lot of the ducks ducks are
different some eat grass and and some
they muck around the bottom of the pond
and eat oysters or clams and so Ducks I
think are usually in the unclean
category I know that there's some
disagreement on that but I figure if
you're in doubt don't eat it because
there are so many other things
everywhere I've been in my life where
they serve duck they serve other things
too
yeahjust I played safe and and you
wouldn't want to get sick okay hey
thanks I sure appreciate that good
question thank you very much
uh-huh talk next - oh by the way Calvin
if you're still listening we do have
that same lesson on God's health plan
talks about the distinctions between the
clean and then clean you're listening to
Bible answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
Time call us at one eight hundred seven
[Music]
the pages of the Bible stories of great
heroes heroes of great deeds great love
and great sacrifice but behind them is
another hero hidden in plain sight amid
the shadows he was there from the
beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry
shadows of light seeing Jesus in all the
Bible get your copy today by calling
855-578-6767 the angels man is a whole
lot lower than God because God says as
the heavens are high above the earth so
are my ways above your ways it means
infinitely higher than us right but if
you look at man and angels angels are
ministering spirits they also are
created beings God made the angels he
made man God did not make himself so
it says you've made him a little lower
than the Angels would have to be
creatures he created see what I'm saying
I see yes I do good question you're
right that that is the word Elohim
they're just you can look in job where
it says the sons of God
I came to present themselves before the
Lord do a search on Elohim I think
you'll see a few other places where the
word is it's not just talking about God
you know for example in the Bible King
David sometimes they called him Lord you
know sometimes people called the ruler
of Egypt Lord I think that even Joseph's
brothers said the Lord of the land
speaking of Joseph certain words that
were words of divinity or lofty words
were interchangeable with God you need
to read the context I understand I'm
sure that makes sense thank you very
much all right hey thank you so much
appreciate that and talking next with
Matthew Matthew calling from Nevada
you're on the air
oh hi thanks for taking my call
absolutely and your question my question
is about deborah and barak when when
Barack refused to go into war without
Deborah do you think he was being a
coward or was he actually doing God's
will and doing what God wanted it to do
or was he just what do you think well
she was a prophetess and it was the
soldiers wanted to go into battle with
the reassurance of God's presence and I
think that he didn't want her to go into
battle as if you know she was going to
be on the frontlines as a secret weapon
sure but the priests often went into
battle you know you could read where
Jehoshaphat went at the battle the
priests went with him and they were
actually playing music when the hophni
and Phinehas went into battle you know
these are their priests the sons of Eli
I think he was saying I want the
presence of God I've not read this as an
act of cowardice I think he was just
saying it's going to be a great support
for us to see you they're cheering us on
let me give you an example when Joshua
went into battle against the Amalekites
he had Moses was standing up on a hill
where they could all see him and when
they saw Moses with his hands lifted up
to God
they were victorious when Moses hands
got tired he put him down
they got defeated the presence of Moses
they are interceding and cheering them
on encouraged them and I suspect that
they wanted Deborah there as a spectator
knowing she was there interceding to
encourage them yeah I think so I think
he was trusting that Deborah was in fact
a prophetess and trusting in what she
had said that God told her yeah so you
know the presence of the Prophet is
always encouraging matter of fact in
that same battle I've talked about with
Jehoshaphat it tells us they brought
Elisha the prophet with them he wasn't
there to shoot an arrow or sling a a
sword he was there just for the moral
support and guidance which he did give
them in the battle Elisha the prophet
went with Jehoshaphat and the king of
Israel into battle against Moab and
Ammon and the and they were
victorious
I'm guessing that's what it was and a
good question Matt I appreciate that you
have a good night god bless
thank you be safe on the road bye bye
all right talking next let me see we got
three minutes before the break can I
talk to Sharon calling from Cleveland
Ohio Sharon you're on the air with Bible
answers live hi pastor Deb how are you
doing good how are you doing good very
good I had a question this evening about
goes okay wondering how I could explain
to some people I know
biblically if they exist or not are
there evil spirits yes the Bible calls
them fallen angels are they resurrected
dead people no the Bible tells us that
dead don't know anything can fallen
angels impersonate the dead yes they did
this in the first book of Samuel King
Saul was fooled by an apparition
claiming to be Samuel the Prophet that
had come back from the dead that's a
ghost nothing in the Bible matter of
fact Isaiah says do not try to
communicate with the dead
Moses said those who consult mediums a
medium is someone who can talk to the
dead spirits those people were to be
stoned no no believer was supposed to be
involved in the dark arts
Paul said have nothing to do with those
works of Darkness so Satan can't
impersonate you know Satan knows my dead
grandma and everybody else and and he
knows what their features and secrets
were and he can impersonate them the
sound of their voice their walking
idiosyncrasies I mean he's a master of
light him and his fallen angels and so
when people say this house is haunted
you know I don't believe in haunted
houses do I believe there are evil
spirits yes I'm not afraid of them but I
have no question there are evil spirits
out there and they can you know do
things and make things go bump in the
night and try to you know make the
curtains move and sounds in the dark and
try and spook people when people say oh
no there's an evil spirit in the house
they say so what don't you believe that
angels are real and good and bad I said
so I have no doubt that they aren't real
okay that's why you know yeah because
they say a good spirit came to them Oh
some friends of yours a dead person yeah
yeah you got to be real careful because
yeah the Bible tells us that the Olivie
know they'll die that dead know not
anything they do not come back to their
house that's in the book of Job you can
reap job 14 in fact I will give you a
Bible study for free and it covers the
subject of ghosts and these evil spirits
and it's called does God inspire
psychics and astrologers and it deals
with fallen angels so if you call the
resource number share and I appreciate
your call call 885 six seven four seven
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and ask for our study guide
on we've got study guide on the
astrologers and the sea sayers we've got
a website called ghost truth go to ghost
truth dot o-r-g
friends were taking a quick break more
bible questions on the way
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
once an old God's plan for our world and
solutions for your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide encouraging
Bible based answers to questions on
healthier relationships when Jesus will
return and much more prefer to watch
while you read our brand new prophecy
encounters DVD series makes the perfect
companion set order your study guides
and DVDs today by visiting AAF bookstore
com or by calling 858 7 275
[Music]
throughout recorded history tales of
ghosts and spirits can be found in
folklore in nearly every country and
culture Egyptians built pyramids to help
guide the spirits of their leaders Rome
sanctioned holidays to honor and appease
the spirits of their dead even the Bible
tells of a king that used a witch to
contact the spirit of a deceased prophet
today ancient folklore of spirits and
apparitions have gone from mere
superstitions to mainstream
entertainment and reality scientific
organisations investigate stories of
hauntings and sightings trying to prove
once and for all the existence of ghosts
even with all the newfound technology
and centuries of stories all over the
world there is still no clear-cut answer
so how do we know what's true why do
these stories persist does it even
matter we invite you to look inside and
find out for yourself visit death truth
dot-com every bible question you have
answered moves you one step closer to
the fullness of God's will for your life
so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 go back to the
husband yes it does say that in in
Deuteronomy God wanted to avoid people
who are married getting divorced trying
out another partner and then saying oh
that didn't work out I'm going to go
back
my first husband or wife to discourage
that behavior God said that if a man
puts away his wife and she becomes
another man's wife he cannot go back and
take his first wife should she be
divorced again at lest you it corrupts
the land and you know what I will send
you a book that talks about that Margit
talks about marriage divorce and
remarriage and I'll send you a free copy
it is eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven ask for the book
marriage divorce and remarriage and
we'll send that to you Marty
thank you for your call Kathy and
Tennessee Kathy you're on the air with
Bible answers live okay it's nice to
meet you talk with you pastor Doug I
appreciate that what was I am reading
the book triumphant truth for my morning
watch book and on one of the dates it
was a question about Satan being
immortal and I understand that he's not
and that it says according to first
Timothy 6 3 through 16 that God alone
has immortality well does that mean then
none no angel do angels die
well the fallen angels the Bible says
that they are going to be cast into the
lake of fire right and you can read that
in Matthew 25 and Jude the book of Jude
but the unfallen angels yep it live
forever they don't get old and die so
they have eternal life just like we will
have eternal life so when the Bible says
God they're not considered immortal are
none fallen angels have immortality but
when the Bible tells us God alone who
has immortality he's talking about those
in the world he's not talking about the
unfallen worlds or angels that are
unfallen i think the context of his his
comments here speaking out here in this
world only God has immortality we're all
going to get old and die now there are a
couple of exceptions you know Elijah and
Enoch went to heaven without dying so
you could say well they're immortal they
were created and they're never gonna die
and then you've got people who are alive
in the world today that may be alive
when Jesus comes I certainly hope I'm
one off
I wouldn't mind at all not having to
find out what death is like but we
receive eternal life when we accept
Jesus but physical immortality comes
with the resurrection of the just okay
alright I appreciate your answer good
question yes thank you very much
all right thank you Cathy all right
we're gonna talk with a Manny in Chicago
Manny welcome to Bible answers live hi
pastor Doug thank you my drive to work
hi how are you well I Drive to work I
see a billboard posted usually I feel
like it's targeted towards Christians
for them to kind of ask themselves well
it says Jesus is in the Quran and
Muhammad is in the Bible do you know I
know you said you have read the Koran do
you know if this is true or not
well to be honest I've not read the
Koran from cover to cover I've read
large excerpts of the Koran it's
sometimes a difficult book to read
because it's it doesn't follow a story
it's just a lot of Proverbs and
statements and utterances that are put
down yes Jesus is mentioned in the Koran
and I've read that of course most people
read the Quran in Arabic I've read some
English translations of it and they
speak highly of Jesus they do not
believe Jesus was the son of God they do
not believe Jesus died on a cross and
Muhammad as far as Muhammad being
mentioned in the Bible the name Muhammad
does not appear in the Bible there's a
prophecy in Revelation that speaks about
this oppressing influence against
Christianity would be a judgment against
Christianity and that's one of the
judgments and they believe that's
Muhammad and Islam that became a great
persecuting force against Christianity
and to this day there's great tension
around the world between those two
religions so if someone puts up a bulb
or a billboard and they try and make it
sound like the religion of Islam and
Christianity can't we all just get along
I can get along with people from all
different backgrounds but as far as our
faith being the same Islam is not the
same as Christianity they do not believe
in the deity of Christ which is a
foundational teaching of Christianity
they do not believe the promise that
made to Abraham regarding Isaac they say
Abraham offered Ishmael on the mountains
of Moriah and so there's I don't believe
Mohammed was inspired and that the Quran
is an inspired book so there's a lot of
division on fundamentals between
Christianity and Islam I've got friends
that are Muslims and we can be friends
we get along fine that we love sit down
you know have a meal with them and enjoy
each other's company but I have to
respectfully disagree on theology that's
a long answer did that make sense did I
lose you - hang on sugar Manny it seems
your call dropped off did you hear my
answer yeah okay thank you did that make
sense yeah thank you all right hey thank
you so much sure appreciate your call
god bless you have a good night all
right let me see talking to Annie
calling from is a Connecticut Annie
you're on the air welcome to the program
thank you I have a question I'm Hispanic
and we have a costume like when we say
hi oh good bye to our children they
always ask for our blessing and we say
god bless you I know Jacob was only
blessed one by his father I'm just
wondering if that okay absolutely
the the paternal blessing were Isaac
placed his hands on Jacob and he placed
his hands later on Esau and Jacob placed
his hands on this his sons and blessed
them the paternal blessing was a solemn
event more like a baptism or a marriage
where the father would do that once but
Moses told the children of Israel that
whenever the priests met with him they
would pronounce a blessing on them and
he probably heard where that phrase were
it says may the Lord bless you and keep
you may the Lord lift up the light of
his countenance upon you and be gracious
to you and give you peace so they would
regularly bless the people even in the
greeting Shalom that the Jews say it is
a blessing of peace
so certainly nothing wrong I saw my kids
this week and I said god bless you this
so nothing wrong with that you want to
pray for God to bless him all the time
especially with spiritual blessings
right
well thank you wonderful thank you all
right thanks good question appreciate
that all right let's see here we're
talking to Rick in New Jersey
rick is calling you're on the air with
Bible answers live Rick I guess my
question tonight I was reading
recounting a story in first chronicles
21 how David took a census and God
became seeing the I agree with David and
he gave him a choice of three
punishments that David had to succumb to
right why was God angry with David for
that was why was his anger so severe
well God had told the children of Israel
that he wanted them to trust him I mean
here you've got David that so many times
in his life he's gone into battle and
he's trusting the Lord it didn't matter
how big Goliath was David won so many
battles with inferior forces and God had
always watched over him God had given
him victory there's stories about David
and his mighty men where David and one
other friend took on a Philistine army I
mean you don't often hear sermons about
that but some of the exploits of David
and his forces so now David is taking a
census to see how big is my kingdom he's
trusting in their numbers instead of
trusting in the Lord it was an issue of
pride in David's heart and even as David
is telling Joab go number the people
Joab is saying why are you doing this
even his general knew that there was
something wrong with why David was doing
this you can read here Joab says and I'm
reading in first chronicles 21 and you
look and think it's verse 3
Joab says why would he be a cause of
guilt in Israel he says you're gonna
bring guilt on us why does my Lord
require this thing meaning the King
David was something that was going on
he's looking at how the Lord had blessed
the kingdom he defeated all their
enemies he's thinking I'm the king of
the world how big is my army and he's
trusting and how many soldiers he's I
better count my soldiers and kind of
like a person starts counting their
money all the time you want
you know what if they're enjoying life
or if they're just coveting money okay
yeah it's not that it's wrong to count a
good shepherd counts as sheep you you
can read the parable where Jesus said
there is a shepherd that had a hundred
sheep and he noticed one was missing
well how does he know one's missing
because he counted them so it's not that
there's a sin and Counting it's that God
didn't want them to trust in their
numbers because God said look one of you
is gonna chase a thousand if I'm with
you Jonathan and his armor-bearer he
said there's no restraint with the Lord
to deliver by many a few the two of us
they took on twenty Philistines so David
was going from the person of faith to a
person of pride and God brought a
judgment on the whole nation you know
it's it's also interesting yeah
interesting story also Rick because this
is the event word finally David sees an
angel with a sword drawn over Jerusalem
over Mount Moriah or Abraham had offered
Isaac and that becomes the place where
the temple is built David prays for his
nation there God stops the plague and
that site becomes the site where the
temple is later built okay let me see
here talking to Nicole Nicole in
Nashville Tennessee hi Nicole you're on
the air hi I'm taking my cell my
question has to do with all the
shootings that have been taking place in
the context of all those is decent
people action and self-defense for the
defense of others justified incisal I
guess how do we reconcile the events of
the Old Testament and Christ saying turn
the other cheek and your other pocket
yeah good question Jesus I love your
enemy turn the other cheek so if you
know someone comes into your house and
they're an armed assailant is it wrong
to use lethal force to stop them
absolutely nothing wrong with that now
someone just sent me an email I guess
has happened
today in Fort Worth yeah you heard about
that yeah they walked into a church and
started shooting people and fortunately
that church had armed security and
somebody was ready and they stopped him
but may have been you know multiple
shootings where I think well at least
one of the congregants died could have
been much worse when Jesus says love
your enemy and turn the other cheek he's
talking about interpersonal
relationships that is very different
from civil law you got personal law and
you get civil law civil law you can
never ask the police just turn the other
cheek if you see a robber going in a
store or bank they are required to
respond and Paul says in the New
Testament that the soldiers the
government Caesar he bears the sword for
a reason and that we should respect that
and when he talks about that he means
you know there are consequences when you
break the law and you're gonna pay those
penalties Paul said you know they don't
bear those sword in vain there is a time
for self-defense and of course in the
Old Testament it's the same God as a New
Testament civil law had to be obeyed and
there were consequences I think that you
know if I'm having an argument with a
brother and he gets upset with me and he
smacks me I might offer him the other
side of the myface not retaliate that's
an interpersonal relationship if I see
an armed assailant are not even armed if
I see a man hitting a woman and she
can't defend herself I have actually had
to do this before it's just why I'm
saying that I will intervene physically
if I need to I was doing some counseling
once years ago and the husband and wife
got into a fight and he started beating
his wife in front of me and I told him
to stop they wanted listen I had to jump
between them and actually wrestle the
guy off of you know beating his wife so
you know I have no regrets about that so
sometimes you must use physical force
those are the civil laws and
interpersonal laws yeah now Jesus said
to Peter
those that live by the sword die by the
sword and of course that's still true
you know we Christians shouldn't say I'm
going to go spread Christianity by
killing people that's what the
conquistadors did and has a really bad
example you can't force a person into
being a Christian but as far as a person
having practical self-defense
you know I'd leave that to every
individual but I don't see any biblical
mandate that says it's wrong for a
person to defend their home that clears
it all up I've always wondered thank you
so much Pat all right thanks so much
Nicole appreciate your call terror
attacks natural disasters political
instability and global economic meltdown
these are the images people generally
associate with the tribulation and the
day of the Lord but did you know the
Bible speaks about another day of the
Lord just before the great Judgment Day
amazingly imprinted on the very fabric
of time itself is a 24-hour period
called the Sabbath that was meant to
forever be a time of restoration for
every human being a day the entire world
is largely forgotten you'll be surprised
to learn how this special day of the
Lord
factors into last day prophecies such as
the mark of the beast the seal of God
and the great final tribulation it's all
contained in this new eye-opening DVD
series called the last day of prophecy
to order call 800 538 7 to 75 or visit a
bookstore com want to know God's plan
for our world and solutions for your
life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide encouraging
Bible based answers to questions on
healthier relationships when Jesus will
return and much more refer to watch
while you read
our brand new prophecy encounters DVD
series makes the perfect companion set
order your study guides and DVDs today
by visiting AAF bookstore calm or by
calling 858 seven two seven five you're
listening to Bible answers live this
broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific Time call us at
[Music]
1-800-555-9408
it'll be almost the same as the King
James Version friends for those who are
listening this is a verse in 1st
Corinthians 15 verse 29 that some people
have been confused I think is Paul
saying it's okay
to baptize four dead people and there's
one denomination that even after people
have been dead and gone for years they
say well I'm gonna get baptized for my
dead relatives and some people be
baptized twenty times for all their dead
relatives and nothing else in the Bible
teaches that you can get baptized in
behalf of another person to save them so
it creates a real theologic quagmire to
think that and then you got people who
say well I'm gonna live a wicked life
and you just get baptized for me when
I'm gone well you know that's like key
to the teaching of purgatory the Bible
doesn't teach that but this is the verse
let me read what it says otherwise this
is first Corinthians 15:29 otherwise
what will they do who are baptized for
the dead if the dead do not rise at all
why then are they baptized for the dead
and people read that that's what it says
and they think oh well it sounds like
people are getting baptized for the dead
it's a punctuation issue 1st Corinthians
15 is all about the resurrection Paul is
saying otherwise what will they do who
are baptized , for the dead are actually
what will they do who are baptized
period for the dead , if the dead do not
rise at all , then why are they baptized
, for the dead question mark he's saying
if the dead don't even get or don't even
rise why would anybody living get
baptized
are you eating baptized for the dead
he's asking it as a rhetorical kind of a
sarcastic question he's talking to
people that are doubting the
resurrection he said why are you
bothering getting baptized if there's no
resurrection why get baptized he getting
baptized so you can stay dead and
baptized you see what I'm saying
if you punctuate it that way Paul is
speaking in a little bit kind of a
rhetorical statement he's not at all
making an argument for getting baptized
for the dead other people read it and
they say maybe the Corinthians had a
practice of baptizing for the dead he's
saying you don't even believe in the
resurrection why are you getting
baptized for the dead he's not condoning
it he's asking them either way he's not
endorsing the practice of baptism for
the dead I believe it's a punctuation
problem there is there is no punctuation
in the original Greek translators are
the ones who put in the punctuation and
that changes the meeting entirely it's
like if I if you're going shopping and I
tell you no price too high you might
think oh I got Doug's credit card no
price is too high but if I say no no
what I said was no comma price too high
a changes it completely it's an opposite
meaning it means don't buy anything the
price is too high
see what I'm saying yeah putting the
commas in the right place here gives a
whole different meaning to it I think
that's the I think that's the solution
all right hey thanks so much appreciate
that Bob hope that helps you a little
bit with that let's see we're gonna keep
going we got Carl calling from Canada
Carl you're on the air with Bible
answers live
after dark evening my question is about
baptism and Ephesians 4 verse 5 it says
one Lord one faith one baptism he that
means it's just one but someone can be
baptized and ones or it just once one
form of baptism good question well when
Paul says one Lord one faith one baptism
now Carl were getting some static so I'm
just putting you on mute for a moment
but when he says one Lord one faith one
baptism he's not saying that you can
never be baptized the second time now
God is not encouraging people to be
baptized multiple times baptisms a
sacred occasion like a marriage but
there are examples in the Bible Acts
chapter 19 you've got an example of
somebody being baptized actually there's
a dozen believers that are baptized a
second time they were baptized by John
the Baptist's and then they're baptized
again by Paul and the Essenes who
practice baptism they're the ones who
lived during the time of John the
Baptist
they owned by the Dead Sea there they
would baptize a person more than once
and so the idea represented a cleansing
and a commitment to the Lord
I don't believe a person once they've
been baptized biblically by immersion
they need to continue to get baptized
now if a person totally denies the Lord
and they backslide they come back again
they may need to be rebaptised if
someone just totally didn't understand
the truth and when they were baptized
and they come into a whole new
understanding of what the truth is in a
commitment to Christ they might get
rebaptised you know you think that maybe
one sin in their life some maybe twice
very rarely if a person's baptized three
times something's wrong it's like you
know when someone gets married five
times you started thinking well wait a
second here but there is no command that
it can only be one time because Paul did
it more than once and he's the one that
wrote Ephesians now could you hear my
answer Carl alright here and before I
lose you I just want to let you know
that we do have a book called baptism is
it really necessary both for you and for
our previous caller had a question on
baptism
and we'll send you a free copy of that
the number is 883 five six seven four
seven to get your free book baptism is
it really necessary oh we might have
time for half a phone call let me see
who's next here ah
Donna calling from Connecticut Donna
you're on the air with Bible answers
live hi hi how are you doing good and
your question um what does the Bible
talk about tattoos well you know there's
one time the Bible mentions tattoos and
that's in Leviticus 19:28 and let me
read it to you okay okay it says you
shall not make any cuttings in your
flesh for the dead nor tattoo any marks
on you for I am the Lord the Bible tells
us our bodies are the Temple of the Holy
Spirit and in the Bible the temple was a
beautiful building with pure white
marble on it God did not want them to
spray graffiti on the exterior of the of
the temple mm-hmm you know our bodies
our skin I believe that God wants us to
respect our bodies where we're probably
not supposed to use our skin like a
billboard to advertise one of the sad
things I find is people tattoo things
that they think is really cool it's a
fad when they're 20 years old or 15
years old or whatever it is and a few
years later it's totally out of style
and then they look silly I knew a girl
that tattooed her boyfriend's name on
her arm and then they had a big fight
and left him and for the next thirty
years she had her boyfriend's name on
her arm didn't even like him so you know
people might think something's cool a
lot of people get tattoos when they're
high and they're drunk and then they
wake up and say Oh what in the world was
I thinking so I you know when you put
marks on your body and they're gonna be
there for a long time I've got another
friend that got tattoos on his face and
nobody would hire him because he looked
kind of scary and he had a very painful
procedure to take the tattoos off his
face I think we ought to stick with what
the Bible says don't you think yeah all
right hey thanks so much for calling
appreciate your call listening friends
were just about out of time for
tonight's program by the way this is the
last pro
Graham of Bible answers live 2019 and
you know if you have not done this
before and you've enjoyed the broadcast
this is a great time to just go to our
website and click that donate button if
you're blessed by the broadcast if
you're edified it's only because other
people have clicked and donated to keep
us on the air we are a hundred percent
supported by people just like you thank
you so much for the privilege of being
able to study the Word of God with you
it is a joy for us and you have a
blessed 2020 around the corner see you
then
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into Satan the
arch-villain the birth of evil a
rebellion in heaven
a mutiny that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation of evil
discover God's amazing plan to save his
children this is a story that involves
every life on Earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love than
what went wrong
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore calm
written by the hand of God and spoken
with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 three eight seven 275 or
visit AF bookstore com
[Music]
for over fifty years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world we build churches in India
proclaim God's Word in China and have
sent free Bible studies around the globe
today's program and free resources were
made possible by our ministry partners
caring individuals like you if you've
been blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with a Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air
so the blessings you've received can be
shared with others to find out more
about becoming
you